bonsoir jean marc rouillan nathalie
ménigon joëlle aubron
georges cipriani arrêté hier soir vers
21h sont considérés comme les chefs
historiques du mouvement terroriste
action directe cette arrestation groupe
et sans effusion de sang est un succès
pour la police tout entière et pas
seulement pour les hommes de l'unité
d'élite qui sont intervenus hier sur la
commune de vitry aux loges dans le
département du loiret le 22 février 87
au matin les habitants de vitry aux
loges découvrent leur village en état de
siège
routes barrées gendarmes au coin de la
rue et hélicoptères en survol à
commencer par celui d'antenne 2 qui
permet à la chaîne de tourner des images
exclusives de la ferme où résidait jean
marc rouillan et nathalie ménigon bien
connue du voisinage sous les noms de
robert et nadine et elke était bien moi
je connais qu'elle elle commence
peut-être nadine vous savez qu'en
réalité c'est nathalie ben oui mais moi
c'était nadine avait toujours été donnée
pour le nom de l'adie est une fille
charmante très gentil que j'aurais
jamais cru ça d'elle on est chez nous
elle mettra rivage avec moi j'ai pas les
gimontois traire les vaches à la main et
emmenait souvent traire les vaches à
lait qui m'ont jeté comme un damné du
petit chai pas dit quand ils ont leur
petit que chaque trêve de meschers et
amener le choix pour traire mes vaches
avec moi que j montre un vitry aux loges
l'épisode action directe fait partie de
l'histoire locale
trente ans après dans les bars du
village qu'il fréquentait parfois
personne n'a oublié
ces gens là je les voyais pas ce que
j'allais à la pêche aussi à côté de chez
eux je voyais tous les jours soit 120 ou
110 et bonjour mais bien boire un petit
coup de temps en temps vous souvenez
deux précisément où l'on est plus
nathalie ménigon - oui avec certitude où
la l'état immatriculé en belgique
sa plaque a terminé à 6 6 moi qui étais
gamin je me rappelle la peugeot
immatriculée en belgique c'est ce petit
détail qui va mettre les enquêteurs sur
la piste
à l'époque la tête des quatre membres du
groupe est affichée dans toutes les
gendarmeries
mais ce ne sont pas les gendarmes locaux
qui vont faire remonter l'information
c'est un policier qui est alerté par
hasard par un ami habitant vitry
oui il avait un ami qui les avaient qui
avaient repéré ces gens qui avaient une
allure un peu bizarre alors ils avaient
ils avaient repéré en particulier qu'ils
avaient une voiture immatriculée en
belgique dans la région d'orléans que
vous connaissez à l'époque et pour
beaucoup de voitures immatriculées en
belgique
et puis bon bain quand il a donné
l'information on a fait évidemment tout
de suite ça c'est ça c'est les rg qu'il
en fait une vérification plaque il est
aperçu et est apparu c'est une voiture
volée c'est vraiment comme ça arrive de
temps en temps le hasard qui a fait que
l'information est remonté aux
renseignements généraux et que à ce
moment là avec une du plan qu'ils ont
ils auraient ils ont vu que c'était
action directe je me souviens comme je
passais tous les joueurs devant pour
aller au boulot on voyait les personnes
dans les fêtes des poteaux électriques
ou téléphoniques que je me souviens plus
et en fin de compte ce dédale a déjà vu
la gendarmerie qui qui faisait style edf
mois après l'arrestation
la ferme du gué giroud devient
rapidement une attraction locale tous
les curieux des environs veulent
s'approcher
j'ai été chargé par monsieur le maire et
ses adjoints de le fermer là le chemin
le jeu installé une barrière parce qu'il
y avait des curieux récupérer un bout de
tuiles ou et on j'ai eu l'honneur enfin
si je peux leur appel à l'honneur de
vider le congélateur avec un de mes
collègues jean-michel il y avait encore
un pétard enfin un pétard sur une chaise
sur une table pardon et enfin petit
pistolet quoi pistolet qui était resté
surpris par l'arrivée du raid
les occupants n'ont pas eu le temps de
faire le ménage ils ont laissé derrière
eux les chantiers en cours
comme cette petite cellule conçu pour un
projet d'enlèvement et des indices
permettant de remonter jusqu'à l'autre
plan du groupe
une maison louée en touraine avis loin
coulanges et
ça vous apprendra qu'on ne devait pas vu
qu'on n'avait rien entendu parler nos
maris leur ai écrit on n'a pas eu de
réponse alors c'est ma fille qui l'a qui
a décidé mon mari d'aller à la
gendarmerie pour savoir ce qu'ils
étaient devenus
on pensait déjà un accident pensez pas
une chose pareille on pensait qu'ils
avaient attrapé un accident qu'il était
mort ça se trouve c'est une chose car à
paris bat tous les deux comme on les a
toujours vu que tous les deux bon alors
c'est là que mon mari les a reconnu sur
une photo la générale les enquêteurs
retracent ainsi le parcours d'action
directe depuis les premiers faits
d'armes le groupe ait lancé en 1979 à
l'initiative de jean marc rouillan et
nathalie ménigon rapidement rejoint par
joëlle aubron et georges cipriani qui
constituent le noyau du plusieurs
dizaines de membres actifs et de
sympathisants les accompagne ensuite
pour des séries d'attentats à l'explosif
qui vise au départ des banques et des
ministères on est alors dans les années
de plomb
des ardéchois des brillants
dès qu'il faut nettoyer souvent pour le
plaisir
et qu'il faut caresser commun pour le
plaisir l'autre celui qui ferait vers la
communion
bonjour à tous le groupe terroriste
d'extrême gauche action directe a donc
basculé dans la violence en assassinant
ir soir de huit balles de 11 43 le
directeur des affaires internationales
au ministère de la défense avec
l'assassinât de ce militaire le général
audran action directe passe à un autre
type d'attentât plus ciblées l'opération
est renouvelée le 17 novembre 86 avec
l'assassinât d'un grand patron georges
besse 20h25 georges besse 58 ans pdg de
renault rentre chez lui au 16 boulevard
edgar quinet
selon des témoignages concordants au
moins deux femmes et peut-être un jeune
homme s'approche de lui
premier coup de feu georges besse
s'écroule une des femmes se penche sur
le corps seconde détonation
le pdg de renault et tu es atteint à la
poitrine et à la tête
les meurtres du général audran et de
georges besse s'inscrivent dans une
période particulièrement violente pour
la france régulièrement des bombes
explosent dans paris et des français
sont pris en otage au liban des actions
revendiquées par des groupes
révolutionnaires libanais que les
enquêteurs savent soutenu par l'iran
ils savent aussi que les groupes
français comme action directe ont
parfois besoin de soutien logistique
dans ce marché de de la criminalité
c'est une trémie nalité politique mais
c'est une trémie dalit est tout de même
il peut y avoir des accords qui se passe
il peut y avoir de la sous traitance
ces gens là se connaissent ils peuvent
se rencontrer en particulier en europe
de l'est
ils ont évidemment toutes facilités de
circulation et de communication donc on
s'est souvent posé la question de savoir
si telle ou telle action ne pouvait pas
être commandité par oui et à ce module à
l'iran si j'avais privé de commanditer
des actions et l'iran à cette époque
mène une guerre secrète contre la france
par l'intermédiaire de groupes armés la
cause du conflit réside dans un accord
de coopération nucléaire signé dans les
années 70
le point de départ c'est l'accord qui
est passé entre le président giscard
d'estaing et du shah d'iran pour la
fourniture à l'iran d'un certain nombre
de centrales nucléaires et également
pour la fourniture à l'iran d'uranium
enrichi avec l'uranium enrichi
on peut fabriquer des bombes atomiques
l'idée ne pose pas de problème à la
france tant que l'iran est dirigé par un
de ses alliés mais la situation change
en 1979 avec l'arrivée au pouvoir de
l'ayatollah khomeini
plus question alors de fournir la bombe
à un pays qui échappent au contrôle des
occidentaux l'iran tente d'abord de
faire valoir ses droits par la voie
légale
puis de manière plus brutale en
soutenant des groupes qui s'attaque aux
intérêts français dans ce conflit rené
audran qui a organisé le soutien
militaire à l'irak est une cible
symbolique tout comme georges besse qui
fut le fondateur d'eurodif
la société créée par la france et l'iran
pour l'enrichissement d'uranium
lusine construite dans la drôme va
d'ailleurs porté son nom après son décès
le problème et savoir pourquoi ils ont
choisi audran et baissent donc la seule
chose qui relie audran hadès
c'est cette affaire d'eurodif
le cas de georges besse oui ils posent
problème parce que comme georges besse
et un des pères du programme nucléaire
français
on peut on peut y voir aussi la main de
l'iran
ça c'est pas une hypothèse c'est pas une
hypothèse d'école
une hypothèse qui est crédible action
directe a pu effectivement être à un
moment commandité pour mener cette
action parce qu'au départ c'était pas
dans la logique d'action directe de
s'occuper de la sphère de rediff
du moins je n'ai pas le sentiment donc
il est possible qu'ils aient pu être
commandité de par les liens qu'ils
avaient à ce moment là sur sur le liban
c'est possible et que il était porteur
d'une mission en échange de quelque
chose de l'argent des moyens action
directe commandités ou manipulés une
thèse qui remet en cause l'image d'un
groupe ce bâton uniquement pour un idéal
révolutionnaire mais qui ne convainc pas
ceux qui les ont côtoyés comme leur
avocat jean louis chalanset
peu importe savoir qui a fait quoi et
qui puissent qu'ils assument la
stabilité politique en tant qu
organisation révolutionnaire comme
chacune des organisations
donc si vous voulez l'instigateur
lui-même
je ne pense pas qu'ils aient un
instigateur différent de même je pense
pas que ça soit des mercenaires
puisqu'au bout ils font pas ça pour
l'argent
donc c'est pas des mercenaires ils n'ont
pas été utilisées par un pays pour que m
des actions on sait très bien que audran
a servi aux ventes d'armes en irak de la
part de la france mais je pense pas sur
les actions directes soit étaient
manipulés par l'iran par rapport à ça
maintenant
encore une fois c'est des thèses hong
kong comme indique souvent manqué des
nouveaux faits mais n'y a pas de faits a
pas d'élément lors de leur procès les
membres d'action directe on refusait de
commenter leur geste et le choix de leur
cible
décédé en 2008 joëlle aubron n'a pas
livré d'explications et ses compagnons
lui que georges cipriani et nathalie
ménigon semble trop affaibli par les
années détention pour s'exprimer
jean marc rouillan lui en liberté
conditionnelle à l'interdiction de
parler des faits pour lesquels il a été
condamné
mais cette mesure prendra fin en 2018 à
ce moment là il pourrait livrer sa
vérité
en attendant il reste une vérité
historique
après la série d'attentats des années 80
et au moment de la libération des otages
du liban la france et l'iran ont trouvé
un accord financier au sujet de rod que
la sphère d'eurodif a servi un aspect la
rançon moi je les dis je les écris on
n'a jamais fait un procès où j'ai vu le
document première ce qu'on veut document
je l'aimais entre les mains vous dire
que la dette 10% de la dette d'eurodif a
servi à payer les autres âges quoi c'est
comme ça après ça a été masqué avec des
montages tout ce que vous voulez mais
dans la négociation c'était la dette
dette d'eurodif été augmentée de la
valeur des otages vous avez exactement
le chiffre
de la dette de renault +10 % outre le
règlement financier
l'accord a aussi permis à l'iran de
récupérer une partie de l'uranium
enrichi produit à l'usiné georges besse
ii la drôme symbole de l'apaisement des
relations entre les deux pays
à la fin des années 90 lors d'une visite
diplomatique à paris
le président iranien était allé déposer
des fleurs sur une tombe pas celle de
georges besse mais celle des pionniers
du nucléaire pierre et marie curie